all right we got a new promo we got a
new promo
hey my fellow zombie squad welcome to
the dustin tv
here in a few minutes you will see my
wrestling promo about
pelosi pelosi
the democrat
i'm doing a promo a wrestling promo on
her
oh hope y'all enjoy the wrestling promo
here we go hello
my fellow americans this is your united
states champion
dustin tv welcome to the channel
do you know the reason why i'm your
united states champion
because i work hard
i love this country and i think this is
the greatest country in the world yeah
the united states of america the land of
the free
opportunity
for anybody yes including
[Music]
anybody who wants to come up come in
this
country you could do what you want in
this country america
so [ __ ] be it run a business
because that's what makes this country
great
to live in here see
we do have a little problems
people
like pelosi that ugly [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you need yes scattered
to go to a hole and bury yourself
whoa [ __ ] you're destroying this country
hell yeah
what we need to do no i need to do
as your united states champion i'm going
to go there
i'm going to remove you from office
pelosi whoa
but relax dustin come down
you need to be stopped
see you think you got the power
no who got the powers the american
people hell yeah
me get her as their united states
champion pelosi
i'm gonna remove you from office
wow because i can because i'm
your united states champion
i represent this country is he saying
this was sort of money in the bank
briefcase where you go in and cash it in
to become the speaker of the house
because if so i mean i'm for reforming
politics so we have that like the
captain america
he's long gone i stand
in his position as the united states
champion pelosi
pack your [ __ ] you got to get the [ __ ]
out because
that's right pack your [ __ ] [ __ ]
dustin's are coming for you
he's coming for you he despised trump
what trump does was trying to make this
country great again
he tried to make
america come first than any other
country
hell yeah because we throw billions of
dollars in the other countries
instead of our own
um somebody been telling dustin things
having him ask has someone been asking
certain questions
about other countries hmm
i'm glad for the thousand two hundred
dollars
stimulus check but i wasn't glad for six
hundred dollars
it just spit in the face of every
american
in this country we need more money
how about this pelosi i'll take your
[ __ ] job
oh [ __ ]
a thousand four hundred dollar stimulus
check that's okay
but if i was in your shoes
guess what the american people will be
getting 3 000
every month every month every month
every month
until this virus ends
pelosi you're an evil [ __ ]
wow you need to be stopped
you need to be stopped
pelosi i put you in the same category
as ello hitler you [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
boy oh boy dustin is coming with the
[ __ ] heat
you're the most evilest woman on the
planet
of earth
you got two more years [ __ ]
every time i see your ugly face
it makes my stomach hurts
let me spin somebody this promo is for
pelosi
oh [ __ ] i want to
challenging pelosi that
evil ugly ass [ __ ] pelosi
i'm challenging you i'll tell you what
let's get it on i will beat your old ass
in a wrestling ring
[Music]
and it's gonna hurt
challenging pelosi to adventures on a
pole match is what's happening right now
folks
but if i win you will leave
the united states of america forever
it's a loser leaves town match
we're having a loser leaves town match
i don't like you and every other country
every other
country don't like you even the american
people don't like your evil ass
see pelosi
you're in the same situation as somebody
else
when lucifer took a [ __ ] pelosi was born
oh [ __ ] evil came out of the devil's ass
good promo so far
pelosi
you're destroying this country
you and your democrats
[Music]
people is ruin this country you
understand
a billions of dollars overseas
for transgender people
and we need that money more
it should be spent here in america
not overseas that's one thing about
trump
he says america first
and guess what america's always giving
this is better than anything at cpac
don't we my american people
we always get [ __ ] on by
the government
pelosi i had freedom of speech to say
this you're an evil [ __ ]
and you need to be stopped
all that money that you got
is in your bank what you need to do is
take that money
and get plastic surgery where you will
look more decent
you ugly [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't like you he doesn't like her and
every other americans don't like
us he's right pelosi he's right
but pelosi i'ma tell you something
[ __ ] your days will come
and you when you went to when you stand
in line
for god to judge you oh [ __ ]
i hope he make you
the devil's [ __ ]
i hope he makes you the
devil's [ __ ]
hey my wow
look at this man look at this man
let's speak to this man
hello dustin i [ __ ] loved your
[ __ ] promo on pelosi it was amazing
oh really no seriously you did a great
job dude
thank you you should have you should
have been speaking at cpac
did you see the video i made on the
haters no i'm gonna do that next there's
a video on the haters is it good
yep oh [ __ ] i gotta check out the video
on the haters
you [ __ ] crushed it dustin
i appreciate it are you tired every time
you're so great in your promo videos and
every time i call you you seem tired
i just actually just got up you just got
up what are you having for breakfast
uh probably some ice cream probably
wait i'm sorry hold on a second
you're doing what now you're having ice
cream for breakfast eating
some ice cream yeah
probably not the best thing to eat ice
cream in the morning right
well i don't have no cereal i mean i
like something sweet in the morning
so you have no cereal so you're eating
ice cream what kind of ice cream
um it's the one that is in the comb
and it's got chocolate uh cover on the
top but it's kind of hard
drumsticks you bite into it it it kind
of
you know breaks it up and then you eat
the uh
vanilla and there's chocolate inside
like
so like chocolate so so drumsticks
yeah drumsticks well look i'm not here
to tell
look you're the champ like i'm not here
to tell the champ let's eat in the
morning so
so that's what you do you rise and grind
you like the rock you get up you have a
drumstick and what's your workout
routine look like
i just kind of helped my dad out in
yards sometimes
yeah digging holes for plants and stuff
and you know helping with the cars
like mechanical and stuff wow you're
like a man of the people you're like
dusty rhodes
i just like to help out people you do no
you're the best and you know you cut a
promo on
on pelosi you voted for trump
yeah voted for trump hell yeah brother
voted for trump
and you think we're spending too many
too much money on trans
people no well i was talking about
too many too much money for other
countries
we need it more than any other country
needs it
we're in this pandemic why should help
your own people instead of
giving giving it to other countries that
we
need it we don't have jobs right now
because of the
virus and we need needed more if i was
president and if i was running the
country everybody will be getting
three thousand dollars every month to
help them out with
groceries paying bills and rent
and some other stuff like doctor bills
and stuff
do we do we do we give too much money to
to like israel you think
yeah we yeah we're giving
every every country money well like
specific but like but like specifically
israel
no i'm just talking about like all
countries but like but but yeah i know i
mean i agree a lot of countries but like
israel is one of them right
yeah one of them yeah one of them no
you're right you're right you're right
i mean we need it more right now i mean
look at a lot of americans
just lost their job because of the covey
you're right man you're absolutely right
and then you know building on that
is um do you know who controls the media
dustin who do you think controls the
media
the people no i know but like who runs
cnn
um the uh
hmm let me see i don't really know who
runs to see it in
well cnn's run by by a jewish man did
you know that
i didn't know that you know who runs
msnbc
oh you don't know no
that's a jewish man did you know that
it's weird right it's weird right
oh yeah i mean how can how can they
relate to the american people their
loyalties to another country
i don't know it's just i mean
the american people give [ __ ] on agree
all the time about you know their old
country
don't want to give them it here's the
here's the kicker it's our money
they're giving our money to other
countries yeah [ __ ]
they take taxes out of our uh they do a
lot of people
working money and then they give it to
other countries
it's crazy right it's it's crazy
yeah it's it's crazy i mean they should
give it back to their own people
in the united states of america that's
right the united states of america not
in other countries in the middle east
right
yeah see trump he was all about
america first hell yeah right's right
right i mean i'm just tired of
us getting suffering through this
pandemic
and they give us hundred dollars
first stimulus check second one was six
hundred dollars really
it's just like here's six hundred
dollars screw y'all
but what do you think what do you think
what do you think of the fat cats in
washington
what we need to do is totally redo
the uh politics and you know get
everybody out
and redo it and make it better right
like some sort of some we
need some sort of solution you know yeah
i mean
i mean this country is going downhill
fast it is it's being so hey you know
what it'd be
would you would you agree that it's
being subverted
yeah it is right it's crazy it's [ __ ]
terrible
we need to go back to american values
yep we need to start building stuff
as here in america instead of the
chinese
that's right you know the goddamn
chinese techno fascist
back in the 50s everything you buy was
made in america
that's a really good point that that's a
really good point
uh you know it's funny back in the 50s
you know you know as a matter of fact
specifically before may 14th 1948 things
were a lot better you know
yeah that date for whatever reason i'm
picking out a thin air
is when things started going downhill
what changed dustin what do you think
changed
what changed is we started buying [ __ ]
from other countries
that's right we did china yeah [ __ ]
china man
you know you know they're they're
electronics
if you get it from china it'll break in
about maybe a month
but if you get it here in america it
will probably last forever
it'll last for [ __ ] ever and you know
what else about the chinese people they
see everything in widescreen which is
weird to me you know
no the chinese wants to run every
[ __ ] the whole world but they're not
going to do it because america's
standing that way
yeah no you're right it's standing in
their way and you know
and why is the chinese women can't drive
it's weird right
yeah to tell you honest truth i would
love to go in their country and just
freaking demolish their um their
politics and [ __ ]
and rebuild their country where they
won't
the chinese people wouldn't be scared of
their own country
yeah the united states american citizens
are scared of their own their own
country
but we we gotta keep we gotta keep
chinese food though right because i like
chinese food
you like chinese food too right yeah
what's your favorite chinese food
[Music]
mostly all of it my favorite chinese
food
is latkes yeah
i tried that it's pretty good mm-hmm
mm-hmm
uh so we're taking them out you're right
though you know these chinese people
think they're better than you know what
the problem with trying
with china in my opinion is dustin i'm
glad i'm talking to somebody that
understands
is they're always putting pee pee in our
coke
have you heard of that oh oh you have
okay you haven't heard the old saying
it's okay i'm gonna teach you one
me chinese me play joke me put pee pee
in your coke
you can have that one dustin that's a
free joke for you
oh i loved your promo man i really did
i'm gonna watch your haters one here in
a second but
i just gotta say you are an inspiration
i was feeling kind of tired this morning
and watching your video really pumps me
up it really does
it pumped me up because who does pelosi
think she is that stupid [ __ ]
hey i think about using her a gator bait
gay
i wouldn't say that because you don't
want you get in trouble but
metaphorically is gator bait right
yeah metaphorically use her as gator
bait we're not gonna do anything crazy
here
but you know i mean i don't have nothing
against um like people wants to come to
this country and they want to work hard
that's right i mean if they want to come
in this country
wait wait wait wait wait but even even
even mexicans
well if they come here illegally
that's right that's right and come and
work
and work hard make money
if they want to run a mexican business
or like a mexican restaurant
that's what makes america great
i mean you guys right you know you're
right a mexican business like a mexican
business like a taco truck or
or like or like landscaping or like
staring at women at gas stations for way
too long whatever business they want to
run
you know who owns almost all gas
stations and hotels now
indians yes why should
america a true american
hard-earned money american
was born here can have their own gas
stations it's always because
buying the indians is always buying
gas stations and hotels and guess who's
giving them the [ __ ] money
the government the government's giving
them money and you know what i agree
with you man
why do indians have to smell like curry
use a toilet for christ's sake
well i i had a cousin um was married to
a
indian indian really and
i told him one time i said you touch her
again
i said you go back to india
in a body bag wow what did he do was he
was he doing was he being mean to her
yeah he was punching the hell out whoa
really why was he hitting her
because it was just the way he he had
he i heard he had multiple wives
indian food indian food is terrible but
you shouldn't hit your indian wife
because of it
no my cousin no no no not you not you my
point is
you misunderstand me just because indian
food is bad doesn't
not you but just because her indian
cooking was bad doesn't mean
oh yeah yeah yeah but anyways he was
hitting on my cousin
and they was married and they got two
kids together
mm-hmm are they are they half and half
so they are they are they little half
and half
they're half indian half white wow
really
does that give them like super powers
no no
well that sucks then what's the point
anyway um
she come she came over and i seen like
bruises on her
what happened and she told me and one
day with that triple a power sports
my uh my sister and her husband used to
own it and run it and he came
up with her i said hey man can i talk to
you for a minute
it's a sure that's how i'm gonna let you
know man
if you ever put your hands on my cousin
again
i kill you did he
did he ever do it again yep he did it
again
he got put in jail and got exported back
to india
he went back to that's terrible that's
the worst thing you do is have to go
india
india is a country it's very hot and
they poop in the streets
well it's the most poorest country in
the world
it is it is the most poorest country in
the world probably because they poop in
the streets
i don't know why they poop in the
streets you poop in the toilet like i do
right dustin
yeah but it ain't not none of our i mean
what is concern to us i mean we're just
looking out for
each other here and you know hell yeah
and the good old us of a
uh so but you know who's worse than
those people no mad sam
well india is better uh any
person is better than no matter sam hell
yeah right because no man who does nomad
sam think he is anyway bothering you all
the time
well i i know he brings his
trolls because every time i do a video i
go to the comment section
sent me [ __ ] porn [ __ ] really
yes no man sam nomad sam is sending you
porn
i know he get one of his trolls to do it
he has to be stopped man it's getting
out of hand i think you and him need to
do some more sort of wrestling match
i think he could take his hip out
no i just do i just do something better
i just freaking uh
when he shows up i have my because i'm
good friends with the sheriff
yeah actually the sheriff i could just
get him to put him in jail
and and freaking go through his van
so you're gonna have a dirty cop plant
drugs in his truck
nope oh i get it i get it
wink wink i'm with you dustin wink
[Laughter]
oh dustin you know man you're you know i
got to say yo you're you are you are
all joking aside you're a ray of
sunshine and i'm very glad to have met
you my friend
yeah i am too man i i really am i i'm
very proud to be a part of the zombie
squad
oh i want to ask you a question sure
you could grow a good beer dude i mean
thank you
i appreciate it man i i i don't have a
lot of hair on top so i got to grow the
beard to make up for it
my head's upside down
oh you just made my day well you know
what i don't want to i don't mean to
bother i know you got to go have your
your
your ice cream ice cream breakfast
what's for lunch
um probably some uh
um translated is it it's in the can
potty meat sandwich what is it
potty meat sandwich i've never heard of
that potty meat
like p-o-t-t-y
actually i'll do a video of explaining
what pottery reviews
pot a potted meat sandwich oh oh that
looks gross dude
i just looking at it ew you like it's
like creamed meat
well i grew up holding it ew oh no
come on i'm looking at it it's just like
oh it's like creamed meat
well i'll do a video on it later on
today
and let's see oh no
oh that's gross i'm looking at it it's
so disgusting
yeah it's like a can of like creamed
meat it's so weird
and what and what's in what's for dinner
oh probably some hot wings see that's
normal food so wait so so i just want to
hold on i'll
be clear today you're going to have a
drumstick you're going to have potted
meat sandwich and hot wings
do you just poop all the time
[Laughter]
you just poop all the time
oh man the part of me i actually grew up
on because
the way my mama was she always give me
part of me to eat and
during uh that time my dad he was
struggling
to make ends meet and we had
a lot of time meat and boiled potatoes
when you know the kid went up real
little
and i still like the stuff i mean
i just i still like it here so you like
potted meat and boiled potatoes you're
just a man of the people i i dust and i
swear to god
oh that boiled potatoes oh my god when
you boil them
put salt and pepper you can make a meal
off of it yeah man boiled potatoes and
creamed meat i mean
that that's a man's that's a man's meal
not cruel not the part of me with the
boiled potatoes i'm talking about like
why not a lot of times my dad always buy
like a couple cans of the pine meat and
we'll put them on sandwiches
eat them for supper or something or we
can
eat boiled potatoes sometimes and then
sometimes
my dad's mom and dad uh
like do suffering they bring food
to us when i was real little
and my dad didn't uh was working
like a lot trying to make ends meet
you know trying to keep the it was it
was hard times
yeah hard times like like dusty rose
he's just a common man
yeah after dusty rose he was a legend
man
he was let me ask you a question so
first question is are you a good dancer
[Music]
no not a really good dancer you know
i could dance i'm sure you could dance
you look like you look like you could
dance i'm seeing though i'm
you have dancing hips now let me ask you
a question
if i were to send you a music video
would you be able to do a dance for it
it has to be one it has to be country
okay no no no this this this is okay so
this is perfect because this
this is this is actually this is
actually country song
oh really uh yeah let me see here uh
let's see um i'm gonna send it to you
i'm gonna send it to you on on the
facebooks
and i'm gonna see if you can uh
make a video because i think it would
it's one of my favorite songs so you'd
be doing me a favor
if you did uh there you go i just sent
it to you it is a country song it's
called life at the outpost it's about a
bunch of cowboys
uh oh yeah get him up yeah oh so you
know the sun yeah
get him up ride yeah
that's a good country it's a good
country song so i would love this i
would love to see you do it
uh well dustin look i'm not i don't mean
i don't i've interrupted you long enough
i know you have a busy day ahead of you
so i don't want to bug you too much
longer
uh hey man thank you for being on the
show and i look forward to i look
forward to your videos every day to be
honest with you
thank you bro i i enjoy watching your
videos
oh well that's awesome do you have a
green screen by the way you do like some
people green screen you or no
no i don't have a green screen i have to
get me one
all right yeah we'll we'll see if we can
work that out for you hey dustin any any
final words you want to say before we
let you go today
uh screw the [ __ ] haters yeah screw
the [ __ ] haters all right dustin you
take care okay
all right man later there goes there he
goes there goes my boy dustin
ain't nobody better in the biz
than the dustin tv